hey guys welcome back to another episode
of awesome build where today we're going
to be prepping for the Wonder Woman
review now there's going to be a lot of
stuff for this review there's a lot of
costumes and stuff like that some props
Doug sent me a list and it's pretty long
a lot of stuff is things that I are
things that I think I can either obtain
or that I have and I can kind of alter
and stuff like that but there is a lot
of stuff to make and to build or at
least alter so let's take a look at the
list and see what we got to do all right
so here's Doug list take a look and see
what we got here so we have either
swords or Spears for the Amazons Wonder
Woman costume including sword shield
lost lasso as well as the dark cloak she
uses to cover costume in the movie when
she's walking around Steve Trevor
costume for Malcolm preferably no green
because it's going to be green screen
bright DC sucks letters written on the
butt of a pair of jeans I'll bring in
the jeans fishing hole two strands of
fishing line or a bond a filament at the
end of one small sign that reads
anti-feminist and at the end of the
other one one that reads anti man social
justice Peck costume for wrap which
he'll probably bring anything is just a
suit pecks assistant outfit for Heather
which again she should bring in the men
in this clothes for Jim Jason and
Malcolm which are basically just
t-shirts and wigs and stuff so young
Diana clothes for Tamra Amazon Queen
costume for IATA Amazon aunt fur for
Heather Amazon clothes for adult Diana
if we have time a cave background for
when young Diana is going to sleep a
picture book with a cover that reads
mother goose vengeful gods
the Batman outfit for Doug Superman
outfit for rapscallion a spray bottle of
water for Tamara and Malcolm to spray
them down to look like they just came
out of the sea
Amazon outfit for Malcolm German soldier
clothes for Jim and Doug cutout boat if
we still have it from the Phantom review
if not no problem I think I have it it's
not completely assembled anymore but
still kind of exist
so maybe general ludendorf costume full
and wig for Rob Sir Patrick costume wig
and mustache for doug soldier outfits
similar to Sameer for Jim Charlie for
Malcolm and in the chief for Doug to
pills for Rob to swallow jelly beans
might work Aires suit of armor for Doug
and a slice of cake alright that's about
it fortunately Tamara's going to handle
all of the Diana costumes and another
thing you didn't mention in here what
she had talked to me before about was
the god-killer sword basically the sword
and then just a hilt because she stabs
him in the sword disappears so majority
of the costumes I think we can build
with stuff in-house however we're going
to be shooting on Tuesday supposed to be
a hundred degrees that day so it's going
to be very warm here so in the studio
itself we don't have any air
conditioning or anything like that so it
gets pretty warm in here when we're
filming a summer time especially if it's
a hundred degrees so I'm assuming it's
going to be a long day or probably going
to take lots of breaks all right well
let's get cracking there's a lot of
stuff so Barney's going to come in and
give me a hand
he's going to handle things like the
book cover and any of the graphics and
stuff like that and I'm gonna see if
he'll do the
general costume so Barney said he had a
shirt or an option that he thought would
work and he's going to come in with that
and some ideas and stuff like that so
that should be cool because I'll be one
thing off my plate not to worry about so
I'm going to start working on Ayanna's
costume and Heather's costume all right
well let's get cracking there's a lot of
stuff to do
[Music]
I mean
you
[Music]
okay
you
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right so it looks fantastic once you
kind of walk us through the process
that's how you threw it all together
okay
couldn't find a jacket no German one to
give this up so I took this is actually
an old gray shirt of mine that happens
to fit rob one of the important things
in doing any costume is to make sure
that they're going to sit on your actor
everything that I'm here with the
exception of these metals here was
printed off the internet looking up
under German World War 1 medals I then
blew them up to the size that we needed
mounted on board the cross because it's
going to be going on and off the
epaulets and these things here on the
side so we have all these they're all
glued on took some regular old some red
tape electrical tape and ran the edges
here and then folded it under to give it
this nice feel like this found a belt
back in our bunch there put this on Jim
came with these that he got at a costume
store so the big question is when Rob
comes in tomorrow is he going to fit
into it all right
fingers crossed is he out like all the
print out and stuff like that these are
a great resolution yeah these are what I
do is that when I take them off the net
I take it to the to the best resolution
I can get I put it on a white sheet of
paper in under word and what I do this
is really a sort of a sneaky thing to do
on my monitor I increase the size of the
image until it totally matches a real
piece of paper held up there oh yeah
then I know exactly what size these are
going to come out then I simply mess
with them print them out in the way we
go yeah sweet from a distance especially
this one because it's got the I got the
board yeah I Hinde it I mean that looks
legit and yeah it looks like
and then there were also things we did
for instance this was the actual cross
was laying on a piece of red material so
he left a little bit of red on it
because I knew that it would match all
this so we sort of add little things to
it to try and make it look a little more
great that really makes it pop and yeah
yeah great work granny has a fantastic
fantastic make sure to watch the actual
review of Wonder Woman you'll see what
it looks like in use yeah alright so for
Heather's costume most of the stuff I
kind of had or could pick up really
quickly I had this top it's the same one
that the same style that I use for
Tamra's original Wonder Woman costume I
have we I think we first used it in the
hocus pocus review for Beth she wore it
and I had done it in a brown I dusted it
comes in black and I dusted it with a
brown spray paint so that it would kind
of give the look of like a tarnished
leather and then I wound up painting it
red for the Wonder Woman costume when we
had to make the first incarnation of the
woman woman costume for Tamara last
season I picked up another one of these
pops and so now I just threw another
dusting kind of of a light brown it's
going to give it that leathery kind of
quality and then I've got some leather
bracers and kind of like generic
gladiator belt and some shin guards and
that's pretty much it I'll probably I've
got some leather belts and stuff like
that I can strap across or and it should
probably do it as you saw the headpiece
I just cut out of a piece of craft foam
I really didn't measure anything whose I
just kind of eyeballed it real quick
based on an image that I had online of
the actual headpiece and then with
thinner pieces of craft foam I just cut
out these different strips hot glue them
on and quick paint job and you know
we're good to go all right so this is
Doug Aries costume he said he kind of
wanted to look like
sauron from Florida rings very spiky
just dark armor so I reused a lot of
parts there's the shredders gauntlets
and stuff and shoulder pieces and the
arm pieces are left over from one of the
witches guards from The Wizard of Oz the
helmet again is the Spartan helmet with
some horns just glued on to it I threw
some texturing on it and yeah lower half
I'm not really sure I still probably
throw some stuff together I just have to
have some kind of like a tunic or
something like that and we're probably
dark clothes underneath so it should be
a very uncomfortable costume all right
well that about wraps up this episode
but I just want to say thanks again to
Barney for all of his hard work and
everything that he did really really
helped out this episode I thought the
work he did and Rob's costume for the
general was awesome and came out
beautiful and all the graphics and stuff
that he he did for the book and
everything everything just came together
really nicely so thank you so much
Barney once again and to you guys at
home thanks so much for watching and
tuning in I'm gonna try to have some
more episodes coming up soon but you
guys Rock don't forget to check me out
on Facebook at James Jim J Roz
I hope this inspires you guys to build
things and make things and do cool stuff
so once again thanks so much for tuning
in you guys Rock see you next time
[Music]
you